tearing crisis
heading for kiev satellite images show a
40-mile long russian military convoy
less than 20 miles away from the city
center
we will have all the latest from kiev
and elsewhere in ukraine as well as
other key cities around the world on the
sixth day
of russia's invasion
[Music]
good afternoon a ukrainian interior
ministry advisor says at least 10 people
have been killed and 35 wounded in a
rocket strike on the country's second
city harkev
six days into the invasion of ukraine a
russian military convoy stretching 40
miles has been identified by satellite
imagery north of the capital kiev as
global leaders continue to condemn
vladimir putin's invasion there has been
a rare intervention from prince charles
who has labelled the russian president's
actions brutal
in ukraine itself resistance remains in
a virtual address to the european
parliament earlier the ukrainian
president vladimir zelinski said
nobody will break us
sky news has verified these pictures
from harkev ukraine's second city
showing a large explosion in the city's
central freedom square the video shows a
missile striking the city's region state
administration building a local leader
said russian strikes hit the building as
well as residential areas
footage obtained from inside the
building shows the scale of the
destruction
let's take a closer look at how the
situation in ukraine has developed as
we've just been saying a large explosion
hit that regional administration
building in harikev's main square this
morning there were also reports of
russian forces shelling the city
overnight in bravari on the outskirts of
the capital kiev an airstrike left a
military airbase on fire
this morning there were reports that
more than 70 ukrainian soldiers were
killed after russian artillery hit a
military base about 60 miles away in the
city of octriac
that's according to the region's
governor
videos have been released showing damage
in sheridan the north ukraine in the
north ukraine's emergency ministry
claims shelling hit a residential
building a market building and a
kindergarten
and in the south the mayor of mariopol
told ukrainian tv this morning that the
port city has been under constant
shelling and that women and children
have been killed and russia is reported
to have surrounded the city of kherson
and is mounting a serious assault there
let's have a look now at the latest
developments and as i was saying prince
charles has said the values of democracy
are under attack in ukraine in the most
unconscionable way adding we are in
solidarity with all those who are
resisting brutal aggression
the prime minister boris johnson is
meeting his counterparts in both poland
and estonia today and visiting british
troops as he pushes for western unity on
the invasion of ukraine
the transport secretary grant shap says
britain has become the first nation to
pass a law involving a total ban of all
ships with any russian connection
whatsoever from entering british ports
and the home office has confirmed it
will be changing the criteria for
ukrainians who can immediately seek
refugee status in the uk previously it
was limited to spouses children under 18
but now it includes grandparents
siblings and adult children
well in the last hour prince charles has
condemned the invasion of ukraine as
brutal aggression he was speaking as he
attended a meeting to mark southend on
sea becoming a city a key wish of mp sir
david amos who was killed in october
what we saw in the terrible tragedy in
south end
was an attack on democracy
on an open society
on freedom itself
we are seeing those same values under
attack today
in ukraine
in the most unconscionable way
in the stand we take here we are in
solidarity
with all those who are resisting brutal
aggression
well the government has been facing
increasing pressure to do more to help
those fleeing ukraine while in poland
the prime minister announced there would
be further support including sponsorship
schemes we have always had a tradition
of welcoming people in in large numbers
from uh from crisis areas from from war
zones so what we're going to do
is we're extending the family
scheme
so that actually very considerable
numbers would be eligible as i as i set
out earlier you could be talking about a
couple of hundred thousand uh maybe more
again additionally we're going to have a
humanitarian scheme and then a scheme by
which uk companies and citizens can
sponsor uh individual ukrainians to come
uh to the to the uk so uh we're doing
exactly what the unhcr
is asking us to do
and we will be in the forefront of
helping the humanitarian crisis
and we will hear from the home secretary
pretty patel she's doing the comments at
about 1 30 so in about 20 minutes
well this morning the ukrainian
president called the recent attack on
harkie of an act of undisguised terror
and a war crime vladimir zelinski
addressed eu leaders in brussels our
country the
freedom square
and
and this is the largest square in europe
and that's true this is called the
freedom square can you imagine this
morning two cruise missiles
hit this freedom square
dozens of killed
once this is the price of freedom we're
fighting
just for our land
and for our freedom
despite the fact
that all like cities of our country are
now blocked
nobody
is going to enter and intervene with our
freedom and country and believe you me
every square
of today no matter what it's called
it's going to be called
as today freedom square
in every city of our country
nobody's going to break us
we're strong
we're ukrainians yesterday 16 children
were killed
again and again president putin is going
to say that is some kind of operation
and we are hitting a military
infrastructure where our children what
kind of military factories do they work
at
what tanks are they going with or
launching cruise missiles he killed 16
people just yesterday
joining me live from kiev is our
security and defense editor deborah
haynes and deborah we just heard
zelensky there talking about that attack
the missile strike on kharkiv what is
the situation in the capital
well there's just been
some news being reported by the reuters
news agency quoting russian news
agencies saying rather ominously that
the russian defense ministry has said
that they will strike ukraine's security
services sites in kiev um and this these
strikes are to avoid information attacks
against russia
were that to be the case were they to do
those sorts of strikes in kiev that
would mean hitting the center of the
city targets in the center which is
something that hasn't happened so far
and would be a very ominous escalation
of a crisis that is in its sixth day and
showing no sign of ending
you've got as well as that those
satellite pictures showing columns of
russian armored vehicles including tanks
weaponry moving towards the capital
about 40 miles long
it seems
very much
ominous for people still in this city
many have fled
lots of people hiding in shelters
whenever the air sirens go of those left
behind but um
as we have seen across the rest of the
country uh the initial targeted cities
have were first including kiev actually
the the surrounding parts of kiev came
under attack from russian forces and
missile fire and initially the ukrainian
forces were able to repel that to resist
that uh to such an extent that the
russian side has now seemingly increased
the amount of firepower that it launches
against
its targets we saw that in kharkiv
you've been talking through um the the
strikes today in fact in that address to
the european parliament the ukrainian
president said that two cruise missiles
were fired at freedom square
in in
kharkiv which is ukraine's second city
uh he said that you know many people
were killed we don't have the final
death toll i think we were reporting
earlier that they'd put the initial
figure at
10 dead but warning that many more
bodies were feared buried in the rubble
and as well as that yesterday in the
same city it came under intense
bombardment potentially from
including cluster munitions according to
the analysis of experts that have looked
at the blast pattern um you know that's
not confirmed but
cluster munitions an indiscriminate
weapon it's banned by prohibited by many
countries
and again a sign of this this this
increased level of violence that the
russian forces seem willing and clearly
able to use against their targets to try
to advance their forces forwards uh in a
campaign that western officials say
hasn't gone as fast as planned but maybe
that was because
the russians had
miscalculated the resistance they would
face and now having recalculated in the
face of the resistance uh upped the
amount of lethal force that they are
going to be using and just one final
point you hear all of these fine words
strong language from across the western
world across the world condemning the
actions of the russian president
urging him to stop
urging an end to this violence but
regardless of those of those warnings
regardless of those pleas and regardless
perhaps most significantly of this
unprecedented wave of sanctions that
have now been imposed on the kremlin and
its associates it's had zero impact on
the ground here uh
the reverse the the level of force on
this ground is increasing there are also
concerns about the potential for belarus
um to maybe get involved too
deborah thank you
let's return now to the prime minister's
news conference in poland and he was
confronted by an emotional ukrainian
journalist who told him that nato must
do more to protect civilians from
russian bombs
daria kaliniuk who's from kiev called on
boris johnson for a no-fly zone over
ukraine
britain guaranteed our security under
budapest memorandum so you are coming to
poland you are not coming to kill prime
minister you are not coming to leave
because you are afraid
because nato is not willing to defend
because nato is afraid of the world war
iii but it is already started and these
are ukrainian children who are there
taking the hit
you're talking about more sanctions
prime minister but roman abramovich is
not sanctioned he's in london his
children are not in the bombardment his
children are there in london
putin's children are in netherlands
in germany
in mansions where all these mansions
seized i don't see that
i see that my family members that my
team members are saying that we are
crying we don't know where to rob
this is what is happening prime minister
well thank you thank you very much for
uh for your questions and and thank you
for for getting here today and i'm glad
that you you have been able to
to get here and i look i just want to
say that i'm acutely conscious that
there is not enough that we can do
uh to
as the uk government uh to help in the
way that you want and i've got to be
honest about that and when you talk
about the the no-fly zone as i said to
vladimir uh zalensky i i think a couple
of times
unfortunately the implication of of that
is that the
the uk and
would be engaged in in shooting down
uh russian
planes uh would be engaged in direct
combat uh with russia that's not
something
uh that
we can do
let's speak to skies alex rossi he's in
dinipro in southeastern ukraine um
alex day six what is the situation like
there
well the big fear here where i am in
dinipro is that the russian invasion
forces could soon be closing in coming
up from the south
following up the dinipro river to try to
cut the country in half
and use this axis really to to work
further towards kiev but also split the
ukrainian military forces so that they
can't
resupply they can't help out to those
cities that are currently encircled and
almost under siege places like
kharkiv to the east of here ukraine's
second city
that place is getting
pretty badly hit it's quite clear there
has been indiscriminate firing
shelling into civilian areas
certainly the mayor of kharkiv is saying
that what's happening there
is not war it is murder by vladimir
putin's forces now we're also hearing um
pretty bad things about what's happening
down in the south of the country along
the coastline of the
sea of azov at mario pool for instance
we think mario paul is pretty much cut
off at the moment surrounded by russian
forces contacts of mine are telling me
that there are um there is now shelling
some of it falling in residential areas
when we were there a few days ago we saw
that for ourselves the indiscriminate
firing of uh grad rockets into civilian
areas causing um huge destruction and
harm and death to civilians so an
extremely worrying situation the
country's on edge people are really very
apprehensive about where all this is
going
okay alex thank you so much we're going
straight to the commons
where the home secretary patel is
speaking
from public services
there is no limit on the numbers
eligible under this route mr speaker
anyone in the ukraine intending to apply
under the family migration route should
contact the dedicated
24-hour home office line for assistance
before applying
ukrainian nationals already in the uk
have been given the option to switch
free of charge to a point space
immigration route or family visa route
visas for ukrainian temporary workers in
some sectors are being extended so that
they can stay until at least the 31st of
december this year as i said yesterday
i've heard some members calling for visa
waivers
with russian
russian troops are seeking to infiltrate
and merge with ukrainian forces
extremists are on the ground in the
region too
[Applause]
mr speaker i'll continue and perhaps the
party member the opposite party members
i'll take their questions later on but i
actually do want to emphasize the the
seriousness of the security situation on
the ground and that is not something
that can be discounted likely at all mr
speaking
extremists are on the ground and they
are in the region too and i'm sure if
the party opposite wanted a security
briefing um from our colleagues we'd
happily provide one but but at the same
time i'm very skeptical of how they
treat and respect security advice
given this and also with putin's
willingness to do violence on british
soil
and in keeping with our approach which
we have retained consistently throughout
all emergency activations including that
of in afghanistan we cannot suspend any
security or biometric biometric checks
on people we welcome to our country we
have a collective duty to keep the
british people safe and this approach is
based on the strongest security advice
mr speaker these measures have been
designed to enable swift implementation
and that is the point swift
implementation without the need for
legislation or changes to immigration
rules the ukrainian people need help
immediately and we are bringing this in
place now
as outlined by the prime minister
earlier today i can also set out phase
two of our bespoke humanitarian support
package for the people of ukraine
firstly we are establishing an expansive
ukrainian family scheme so that british
nationals and people settled in the uk
can bring a wider group of family
members to the uk extend ineligibility
to parents grandparents adult offspring
siblings and their immediate family
members again the scheme will be free
those joining family in the uk will be
granted leave for an initial period of
12 months they will be able to work and
access public funds
secondly we will establish a
humanitarian sponsorship pathway which
will open up a route to the uk for
ukrainians who may not have family ties
with the uk but who are able to match
with individuals charities businesses
and community groups
those who come under this scheme will
also be granted lee for an initial
period of 12 months and they will be
able to work and have access to public
services
the home office will work closely with
all our international partners on the
ground to ensure that displaced
ukrainians
that are in need of a home are supported
my colleague the secretary of state for
leveling up will work with the devolved
administrations to ensure that those who
want to sponsor an individual or a
family can volunteer and be matched
quickly with ukrainians in need
there will be no numerical limit on this
scheme and we will welcome as many
ukrainians as wish to come and have
match sponsors
making a success of the new humanitarian
sponsorship pathway will require a
national effort from the entire country
and mr speaker our country will rise to
that challenge
mr speaker this is a very generous and
this is an expansive and unprecedented
package
it will mean that the british public and
the ukrainian diaspora can support
displaced ukrainians in the uk
until they are able to return to a free
and a sovereign ukraine
we are striking a blow
for democracy and freedom against
tyranny above all we are doing right by
the courageous people of ukraine
we will help british nationals and their
families to get out of ukraine safely we
will support our displaced ukrainian
friends we will robustly we will respond
robustly to russian threats here
in the uk
we mr speaker will not back down we will
do what is right and mr speaker i
commend this statement to the house
shall the home secretary
thank you mr speaker
people's homes in kharkiv have been
shelled children have been killed
and russian tanks are rolling in now on
kiev
the ukrainian people are showing immense
courage and resolve
in the space in the face of a despot and
in the face
of unparalleled aggression and we need
to do our bit to support them alongside
sanctions alongside the equipment
assistance that also means being
prepared to do our bit to provide
sanctuary as well
families are being split up often
fathers and older children staying to
fight mothers grandparents and younger
children leaving to find safety and
sanctuary and many of those families
want to stay close by to home but for
those who want to travel to the uk to
seek shelter with family or friends and
get the support they need at this
dreadful time we must be ready to help
and we must be ready to do our bit
alongside other countries as we have
done in generations past to give
sanctuary to those fleeing war in europe
we have been calling repeatedly on the
government to do more to help and there
will be considerable relief that the
government has now changed its position
and accepted we must do more
and in particular i am glad the
government now appears to have
completely changed its policy in
response to our calls to help elderly
parents and wider family members and i'm
glad
that they have listened not just to
those in this house but across the
country and most importantly of all to
ukrainians and their families
but i have many questions about how this
will actually work and how many people
in practice it will help
and i am concerned about the way the
home office has handled this but those
are issues for another day we start with
the family issues we are very glad to
know that valentina klimova in paris can
now come to join her daughter having
been initially refused but can i ask her
she has had to pay
around 700 pounds to apply for visas
having been initially turned down can
you confirm
that that money will be refunded to her
and that nobody will have to pay if they
are seeking sanctuary from ukraine
the statement also says her statement
says that elderly parents
siblings and adult children will now be
included in the family visa does that
include stepchildren i have been
contacted by someone for example
desperate to get his step-daughter and
grandchild granddaughter into the
country
and what about a young mom with her
children who has left the rest of her
family in ukraine can she come and stay
with her uncle and aunt our uncles and
aunts included
does the sponsoring family member have
to be british or have to have indefinite
leave to remain what about ukrainians
here on work visas on study visas who've
come maybe as lorry drivers or on
visitor visas
surely she is not expecting to turn
their families away when people are
fleeing russian authoritarianism and war
i assume she will not be applying a test
based on which bureaucratic box uk
residents tick so can she make a single
a simple commitment now
that family members from ukraine who are
fleeing persecution are all welcome here
in the uk no matter what visa their
family member here in the uk has we will
give them sanctuary
and what about people who have been
given the chance to stay with friends we
know most people want to stay in a
ukraine but what about someone who has
left or their family behind but maybe
used to work or study here in britain
can they come and get sanctuary is there
a route for them if the only route is
the community route i'm concerned that
that will take a long time
has the government considered an
emergency humanitarian or protection
visa for example that could still
include all the significant security and
biometric checks she has talked about
but could swiftly be done and go broader
than family members too
we're gonna leave the commons that was
an announcement by um pretty patel about
ukrainian refugees who wanted to come to
the uk they've changed the criteria
it is now grandparents siblings and
adult children of ukrainians in the uk
who can seek refugee status this is also
going to be another um
another scheme where individuals will be
able to sponsor um ukrainians who want
to come to the uk let's go direct
to dmitry bella the
ukrainian foreign minister military
assistants will be coming in
[Music]
there is an unprecedented
level of assistance that we are
receiving right now
finland
is a neutral country
and they are providing military
assistance to ukraine
first time in history last time it
happened
was in 1939
when they
soviet
union attacked finland since then and
since the second world war we all know
that there was a different world since
that time
finland never
provided its weapons to anyone
but it has changed this rule for the
sake of ukraine
sweden decided to provide military
assistance to ukraine sorry i mix it all
up
finland did not provide assistance but
sweden
provided assistance to ukraine in 1939
first time when they were helping
finland
next we're not stopping here norway
approved exceptional decision
to support
ukraine
stepping away from this rule of not
providing assistance to a country which
is not a part of
nato
luxembourg is providing anti-tank
equipment for ukraine
neutral austria is
sending helmets
and safety jackets to ukraine right now
we have the
the ukrainian foreign minister there
dimitrov is speaking giving his daily
update and just updating us on who has
given support within europe militarily
or other otherwise
well the head of the european commission
ursula wonderlion said russians invasion
of ukraine had united the 27 nation
european union and the nato military
alliance let's speak to our
correspondent laura bundok who's in
brussels uh laura that was quite an
extraordinary session of the european
parliament we saw earlier wasn't it
yeah it really was i mean there was a
standing ovation for president zielenski
before he joined via a video link there
were members of the parliament holding
ukrainian uh supporting banners and that
applause echo throughout the entire
chamber it was a really powerful speech
it was impassioned and it felt personal
as well the interpreter even almost
breaking down in tears as he spoke
zelensky's words
speaking on behalf of the ukrainian
people zelensky told the parliament we
have proven our strength
we have proven we are the same as you do
prove you will not let us go prove that
you indeed are european and another
round of applause a standing ovation at
the end of that speech as i say a very
very powerful message as he had told the
mep sat there of the devastation caused
in the last 24 hours with two cruise
missiles he said
directed at freedom square killing
dozens of people including civilians the
european response very strong too
wanting to show that they are united
saying that they are an ally they are a
friend of ukraine that they stand with
ukraine let's have a listen now to the
european parliament president roberta
metzola here's how she addressed
parliament earlier
on behalf of the european parliament
i condemn
the russian military aggression
against ukraine
in the strongest possible terms
and express my solidarity
with all those suffering
and all those killed
[Applause]
point of whether or not ukraine could
become a member of the eu we know the
application was submitted we saw the
photo of president zelinski signing that
application the eu in eu in response has
said it has accepted it has accepted its
application for candidate status it
won't be a fast process though but at
least for the point of view of ukraine
ukraine it is in play now now a very
very strong speech also from the
president of the european commission
ursula van der laan speaking saying how
if putin had sought to divide the
european union then he had had the
opposite effect she said it is a moment
where we cannot take our security for
granted reminding uh the parliament of
europe's commitment now to these tough
financial sanctions tough economic
sanctions to saying how they wanted to
hit putin his oligarchs hard and would
be prepared to go further freezing the
assets of the likes of super yachts of
luxury homes of fancy cars she said she
admitted that there was a two uh too
heavy reliance within the eu on russian
fuel that was in turn uh paying
the war chest of russia and that needed
to diversify that needed to change and
she said that although sanctions would
come at a cost to europe as well as to
russian she said freedom is priceless
okay laura thank you
will the eu us and british diplomats
have walked out of the u.n human rights
council meeting that was taking place in
geneva earlier and that was during a
virtual speech by the russian foreign
minister sergey lavrov
during his speech mr lavrov accused the
eu of engaging in a russophobic frenzy
by supplying lethal weapons to ukraine
let's speak to a correspondent alice de
bunkel who's in geneva and what else did
lavrov say alistair
well he wasn't here in person so he
delivered that speech virtually as you
said and when he got up uh to do it or
when he appeared on the screen i should
say
the room was vacated by western
diplomats there in a show of solidarity
towards ukraine and they went outside
the chamber and they got together in a
circle and they held together the
ukrainian flag
have a listen though to what mr lavrov
did say albeit to a far empty chamber
than perhaps he intended
members of the european union have
chosen a unilateral path of illegitimate
sanctions to evade a direct face-to-face
dialogue
the purpose of our action is to save the
people of donbass by fulfilling our
obligations as allies and to
demilitarize and de-nazify ukraine
so that such a thing will never happen
again
this is particularly relevant in light
of the fact that this country is being
dragged into nato
that the country is being flooded with
offensive weapons and this is a country
that has openly made territorial claims
against the russian federation and
threatened to use force and to acquire
military nuclear capabilities
it's a pretty strong message of
solidarity diplomatic solidarity from
the west towards ukraine there um
no uh remarks about it from sergey
lavrov or the russian government you
know i wouldn't be surprised if they try
and spin it to their advantage and
describe it as a display of diplomatic
rudeness from the
west alastair thank you
well joining me now is our senior zenyuk
he's the former prime minister of
ukraine so thank you so much for talking
to us
i just
i i just want to get your reaction to
your president's speech at the european
parliament earlier
well i do commend his speech and i do
have full respect and confidence in my
president but i have
strong respect in and confidence in the
ukrainian military and ukrainian armed
forces and ukrainian men and women in
the uniform
nobody expected that ukrainians will
fight like hell for our country for our
homeless for our independence
and you know the time has come when
ukraine decided to apply for eu
membership
we expected that this would happen under
different circumstances
but at least we believe that the
european union realized that russia is a
belligerent state
russia is a real aggressor and it is
threat to the free will
and you just showed lavro
and i believe that the time will come
when mr lavrov together with his boss mr
putin will sit behind the bars
in cake in international criminal court
it was quite something wasn't it when
your president said that with that
you've had to pay such a heavy price
for this unity that we're seeing in the
west
you know that's unbelievable
could you imagine
that in this century
we are facing an invasion from b5
members
from russia who actually lied to the
entire world that they will never invade
ukraine
could you just imagine that they are
killing innocent people
innocent ukrainians for what
that we
admire freedom
that we believe in the free world
that we respect human liberties that we
want to have our country independent
so
that's not the challenge
that's even that's more
this is this is the claim this is an
appeal this is the threat
i beg the free world
to help and to save ukraine
you have to press tougher stronger
sanctions
russian oligarchs russian people because
they supported putin
they have to realize that they will pay
the price not only putin and his cronies
but they who supported putin in these
atrocities against innocent ukrainians
we're constantly told that these
sanctions that have already been placed
on russia on the oligarchs and putin
himself or the swift system that they
are the most severe
that we've ever seen
do you think that they are enough
we need to look at the results of these
sanctions
if the russian ruble plummets this is to
be a junk currency
if russian stocks become
will be a toxic stocks if russian
enterprises
will be an enterprises with no interest
overseas if russian gas and oil will be
banned to sell in europe and in the
world so this would be
the measurement of effectiveness of
these kind of sanctions this is it
the world the free world has to wage a
financial economic and geopolitical war
against these bloody heather style
aggressor who is putin
we are fighting with our arms with the
men and women in in uniform please help
us with an economic financial and
political war
against this belligerent state which is
russian federation
do you think it should be more than that
now do you think because the argument is
always well
we can't help them militarily because
they're not a member of nato do you
think that the world now has a moral
obligation to come in there and help you
militarily
i do believe that the world has moral
obligation
because look at this strong ukrainian
nation who has shown an unbelievable
resilience
who is fighting like hell
so
all these efforts to appease the beast
resembled me
1938 with hitler now i want to be very
clear that the free world realized
that no more appeasement
that ukraine is fighting for its
independence and the world is really
helping ukraine with a little uh
defensive weapon supply with the very
top sanction with this financial support
but please do more we are fighting for
our independence and we are fighting for
your independence and for your freedom
and for your sovereignty we are fighting
for the world without dictators for the
world without crazy presidents unhinged
presidents like putin
mr um yet senior you said a moment ago
that it's difficult to imagine or can we
imagine what's going on and for so many
people it is very difficult to imagine
what's going on so can you tell us what
you're experiencing where you are and
what is happening
people are united
people are fighting
people are scared
look at this death toll
of innocent civilians
look at the resilience of the ukrainian
military and the ukrainian army
so we are fighting for our country our
families for our land we are fighting
for our future
there is no other way
no other way
we will survive
i obviously don't want you to
say exactly where you are but in terms
of the capital
we're seeing that convoy a 40 mile long
military convoy making it way making its
way to the capital
what what is your worst fear sir
well i want to be very clear i'm in
ukraine
i'm with the ukrainian people
i do what i can do
to help my country and my fellow
citizens
as far as i understand uh
putin decided actually to seize a number
of uh ukrainian cities including capital
and we have to withstand this
that's the reason why we need
defensive weapon we need little weapons
to support ukrainian military
um so he made a number of
miscalculations he didn't expect this
kind of strong resilience
and once again
i still believe i am confident that we
will survive
that ukraine will win
how do you feel that we keep hearing
about these sanctions and these economic
um
measures that are being put
on
russia the people in government people
around putin and yet still
it's day six
you know day six of this invasion that
convoy's on its way we saw kharkiv two
cruise missiles on freedom square your
president said
absolutely
absolutely so the west has to ramp up
sanctions ramp up pressure
to increase support of ukrainian
military just
save ukraine and save the world
[Music]
former prime minister of ukraine we wish
you well thank you very much for talking
to us
well russia are already feeling the
effects of massive economic sanctions
and increasing dissent within the
country let's speak to our moscow
correspondent diana magnay diana
interesting there to hear the former
prime minister say we need more
sanctions
yes but i think that unfortunately the
sanctions are a punishment but they are
not a deterrent and they are not going
to deter vladimir putin from doing
whatever it is that he wants to do in
ukraine
and in fact i think that the more he
feels attacked by the west the more
vigorously he'll strike back and that is
the unfortunate thing and listening to
our senior yet senior they're talking
about the fact that the ukrainians are
fighting for their future which they are
it is also a case that vladimir putin
has just ripped the future away from the
entire russian public
for
generations um you know they will go
back in time there won't be because of
export controls the kind of technology
that people their peers in the west will
have uh they won't be able to have spare
parts for
their boeing and airbus fleets so
they'll have to start rebuilding their
sukhoi jets which are vastly inferior
someone will make money somewhere along
the way but for the next 10 years while
they're building up that industry those
planes aren't going to be very good
or
telephones you know everybody here well
not everybody of course but lots of
people use apple technology that'll go
all of these things that people are
accustomed to and for example moscow is
an incredibly convenient city it won't
be for much longer
and i'm not sure that the russian people
really recognize at this stage how bad
it's going to get
we saw the ruble collapse yesterday and
we have seen lines at cash points and
people will feel it but they aren't
really yet
uh but they won't be able to travel as
much their ruble won't buy them anything
those who have money in sanctioned banks
like spare bank and that's a lot of
people around the country won't be able
to withdraw cash with it abroad visa and
mastercard are now stopped it you know i
went into a shop the other day and they
said they're not going to be selling any
imported goods because um
they don't know what price to mark them
up as uh inflation is going to go up the
interest rate from the central bank has
just
gone up to 20
from um about 7.5 yesterday to try and
mitigate the collapse of the ruble but
these are all very dramatic steps and
the officials are saying that it doesn't
matter uh we had from dmitry medvedev
who was once supposedly liberal seeming
um president in his tenure when uh
president putin stepped aside for him to
be president for four years he has been
particularly pugnacious recently and and
this is this is uh this is what he said
today um economic wars quite often turn
into real ones so you should watch out
from the kremlin spokesman today he
responding to whether he cared about the
sanctions that have been placed
individually on him and on so many other
officials in this administration and he
said we have no assets in the west we
have no accounts in the west punish us
we are not scared um and i'm sure that
the
uh that the central bank and the
government will try and mitigate the
effects of the sanctions they will um
build up counter-sanction strategies but
you know freezing the assets of the
central bank which has now happened in
many countries where those foreign
reserves are held makes a massive impact
um russia has had to ask companies to
like the big oil and gas exporters to
sell off 80 percent of their foreign
reserve assets to prop up the ruble
because they couldn't use their own
foreign currency reserves um this is
just the start of what will be long-term
economic pain and even if the elites
aren't all that bothered or certainly
the
political ones who were speaking out
there are
many who are michael friedman one of the
biggest oligarchs in this country has
said that war doesn't serve anyone's
purpose he's just stepped down
of the board of directors of alpha bank
oleg deripaska another famous oligarch
has been speaking out against the war
about the economic problems that will
happen i think you'll have more and more
people uh speaking out but fundamentally
it is the people who will be affected
worse by these kinds of incredibly
hard-hitting sanctions and they will be
affected for a long time to come
okay diana thank you
you're watching sky news today coming up
donations flood in for ukrainian
refugees we're going to be live at a hub
in south london next
[Music]
they've pushed the protesters further
back here there's around two or three
hundred still remaining
i'm dan whitehead and i'm sky news's
west of england correspondent
[Music]
this fan goes onto the streets of
plymouth seven days a week 365 days a
year these facilities are at the moment
a lifesaver
[Music]
from fishing communities to bustling
cities we spend every day reporting from
across the region hearing from people
who have real stories
i have nowhere to live for
about three or four months
there are still people inside the
properties here
they're coming from the epicentre of
what is now a global health pandemic
we were seeing and speaking to young
women who were selling themselves right
on the high street it was desperately
sad and the fact it was happening right
in the hearts of this community
before brexit these oysters were being
exported to the eu but the trade stopped
overnight
what's your feeling about the future
blake
might all be
finished i don't know
[Applause]
[Music]
donation hubs have been set up across
london to gather together much needed
supplies for ukrainian refugees like
speak to scarce ash and her like she's
one in one of those hubs in south london
um ashley what's happening there
well just three days ago this space was
hosting a wedding and now look at it
since they put out a plea for donations
they have seen they've been inundated i
should say with
hundreds and thousands and thousands of
items
so many people have been coming here to
this club essentially this community
center in in south london and donating
things like clothing like shoes and look
at the sheer scale of it almost a
mountain of bags everywhere and as you
can see there are volunteers now
hundreds of them have come down just
trying to help they are seeing what is
going on in ukraine just you know
thousands of miles away and they're
thinking what can we do to help feeling
helpless and so lots of people are doing
things like packing sorting through lots
of donations so children's clothes
adults clothes uh shoes
bedding sleeping bags and then there's a
woman over here doing some labeling um
excuse me do you mind me asking when did
you start volunteering only today here
on me today what made you want to come
and join the effort i feel really
sorry for the people in ukraine and my
husband is ukrainian he's here
and this is the only thing we can do is
how we can help we can donate and we can
sort out the things and people have been
donating so much haven't they what sort
of things are you seeing donation you're
holding gloves here right everything
everything lots of uh
bedding lots of clothes some of them
very good quality shoes
hearts um anything anything that's
everything lots of toiletries nappies um
we still need medicines we still need
enough peace we still need
sanitary towels
um
sleeping bags sleeping mats all this
stuff for the army and for people
sleeping roughly
so much i'll let you carry on but as you
can see so as that lady was telling us
they're still looking for lots of new
items they're saying at the moment
they're being inundated with older
things but they're saying first aid kits
or what they need rucksacks but most
importantly
practical items really that are going to
keep people warm who are fleeing and
leaving behind all of all that they know
this section is for children's clothes
this lady here is just packing up
another bag of items and each one is
being labeled um women's shoes what else
can i see around me i can see sleeping
bags here men's shoes but you can see
right at the back there that's actually
a stage that's where on saturday they
had a band performing for a wedding but
you can't you can't even see that you
can see the lights for the stage but you
can see this mountain of bags of
suitcases
of people desperate to help and people
there at the back they're just chucking
items into the bag you really get a
sense that people are desperate to help
and this is really
all that they can do whilst the fight
goes on thousands of miles away
yeah ashna thank you so much
now a brewery in western ukraine is
determined to help defend the nation
against russian aggression with an
alternative kind of cocktail usually the
producers of craft beers the brewers
brewers excuse me are now contributing
to the war effort by
producing molotov cocktails in their
signature brew bottles yuri stavni spoke
with sky news earlier this morning west
ukraine where vr has long history of
fighting uh the russians since
1939
and talking about the situation now
there is a high time in
everyone's life when you really have
to mobilize yourself to use all your
knowledge all your energy
everything you've lived for and
everything you live you've gained in
life to turn it into
making
the fall of this empire possible making
the future of your kids better and this
is what we do
we collected that we put together our
own money
and we started to
we actually we built on our knowledge of
chemistry and our experience from 2014
myban revolution to make good quality
volatile cocktails
and this is about the time when you have
to do what you
can do
and even more when you have to do this
so i mean you so locals are coming to
help you your workers are helping you
and you're producing what how many
molotov cocktails a day are you
producing
well we've only been doing this for uh
three days because uh the war is
actually like a hundred plus hours yeah
so we it's not a it's not an established
operation in a way yeah first day we we
did three to four hundred next day we
did more so far we had a small break
because we've stopped we've stocked the
road blocks that that require them part
of them go to kiev but it's not a very
transportable thing so we we make them
as
as the need comes
and we have a flood of people who want
to donate money for this we we're
collecting local currency we're
collecting collecting euros and u.s
dollars to our accounts
and people actually bring us empty
bottles use machinery oil magnesium
powder and everything
and then we use our own
labor
in a safe way because we know how to do
it in a safe way because we are in that
kind of food production
and
we are renewing this effort uh actually
today
it's the time
when it's now or never um
the
russian enemy which who came to our land
has to stop and we will do everything
all ukrainians women men
all ages all social statuses they all
are everybody is making everything
possible for this to stop and to really
turn the situation around we have
already disrupted the plans of the
dictator to uh to have a blitzkrieg
and that's already a good win now we
have to continue fighting we are doing
it not only for us we are also doing it
for europe and we are doing for the we
are doing it for the whole world because
it's really the base human things that
underline this there is no other way to
do we must be winning this war
a couple of lines to bring you before we
end here um the russian tass news agency
reuters
as saying that
tas is they're quoting a source on the
russian side saying that the second
round of those russian ukrainian peace
talks is planned for march the second
the first round took place on monday no
real tangible results but that they had
said that they would meet again in the
coming days so task news agency which is
russians saying a russian assault on the
russian side has said that the second
round of those peace talks will take
place tomorrow march the 2nd and also
italy is moving its embassy in ukraine
to lev from kiev you're watching sky
news lots more still to come here russia
invades ukraine
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
uh
[Music]
you